how do you keep dealing with this i'm
over it janelle wanted to come janelle
it's happening it's happening oh it's
happening well
maybe
i have no idea about teen mom i have no
idea about my own show
but i know that i've been
in talks with certain people here and
there not saying it's mtv not saying
yeah janelle evans played coy about a
possible reality tv return back in 2020
after leaving teen mom 2 a year earlier
fired from the show thanks to a string
of controversies including her husband
shooting their family dog
we'll see if something works out in the
future fast forward to 2022
and
is teasing her comeback in our first
look at teen mom the next chapter
janelle wanted to come janelle is
happening it's happening that's how the
trailer for the new series ends a
guessing game on whether janelle's
coming back in this life you gotta help
each other you're on probation deserves
a celebration i think you guys will get
married one day we're in the best spot
we've ever been the show's a bit of a
reboot for the franchise combining the
stars of teen mom og and teen mom 2 into
1 show
following the success of teen mom family
reunion specials mtv put together
earlier this year it's time for us to
start getting real with each other i
feel like this teen mom family union is
just a new beginning for our franchise
and this is not gonna be the last time
that we all get together we plan on
doing this again and just doing it
bigger that show already played around
with bringing back a controversial cast
member farrah abraham
hi
uh-oh who the
invited
when she came in it was just kind of
like
she came next to me and i'm just kind of
like why um
and then you know we i really had to you
know kind of think you know
you know
macy had said this every you know a lot
of people said this so far like
everybody should be there
everybody had their right to be there
and farah had the right to be there
because she was a part of the original
og's no matter what
so it won't be a total shocker if
janelle does show up on the next chapter
so guess what today is the kid's first
day of school yeah it's still july too
are you guys excited i'm not second
grade
what are you going to wensley
uh
kindergarten
but even if she doesn't fans can keep up
with janelle and her kids on social
media
her son jace is now 13. 13 years ago
jace was born that's right it was his
13th birthday this week we went to olive
garden for lunch picked up his cake
you like it
next it was time to blow out his candles
[Music]
he hates our horrible singing
can you believe that kid who's been a
part of janelle's journey on the
franchise since 2011 was once this
little guy
there you go
so while janelle's mtv return is tbd
we do know amber portwood brianna de
jesus cheyenne floyd leah messer and
macy bookout are set to star on the
spin-off
i'm in this for life the show's been
great to me my family and i'm forever
grateful i'm ready for life what should
i stacy
now don't get me wrong i like think
about not doing it every season but
mainly just for the kids like billy's
getting older and stuff you know
but at this point i'm like son everybody
thinks you're you're like america's
nephew like yeah
you don't really you're you're kind of
already screwed i'm sorry about that
but um
no i think um
i love the the purpose of the show i
love
the purpose that all of us moms have
for doing the show and what our goal is
and
i'm in i'm in for life too
[Music]